the suspect did uh take responsibility
for things
um he uh stood that early on once we
began the interviews with him
um he claims that these and as the chief
said we know this is still early but he
does claim that it was not racially
motivated
he apparently has an issue what he
considers a
association and sees these locations as
something that allows him to um
to go to these places and it's a
temptation for him that he wanted to
eliminate um
like i said it's still early on but that
was those were comments that he made
did he discuss any kind of religious uh
motivation for this or was he
responsible
religiously or political non-political
i've heard nothing about politics
any sense of his social media history is
that something he's been able to look at
that's something that investigators and
they've been working on how long and
that's certainly one of the things
they'll be doing
sheriff did you have the sense that he
understood the gravity of what he did
i spoke with investigators they
interviewed him this morning and i they
got that impression that yes he
he understood um the gravity of it and
he was
pretty much fed up and then kind of end
of his rope and uh
and yesterday was a really bad day for
him and this is what he did all right
so basically he said that it was a
really bad day for him that what the
suspect is doing uh was uh not racially
motivated
all the spots that were hit were with
haitian people
the people that were killed who haitian
haitian
oh asian you're right good i'm bad okay
that's confused i was like did i miss it
haitians what cooper that we got no all
right every spot that was hit was
asian people all of them and it was all
four girls so yeah he admitted he had a
problem that's not a problem but all the
people that were
killed were asian there is something
he could claim that it's not racially
motivated but
bruh the people you snap were asians
but i mean if you're gonna hit massage
parlors and the only people that work
their asians is that necessarily richly
motivated that's why you cannot think
about it i'm not saying i'm asking you
no you're right people on social media
say it's undoubtedly richly motivated
and here's what i would say
if you want to make the argument that
you know there's um a whole culture in
regards to how
white folks view asians and and that
kind of dynamic
and the reason why people work in those
massage parlors because of that dynamic
there's a broader discussion to have
that i'm probably not apt
to have absolutely if i look at this in
a vacuum could i say
that this is probably not i couldn't say
because you know if you don't have the
details and the suspect doesn't say so
or indicates any type of way it's hard
to tell
however i think why people feel so much
about this my suspicion
is that because when black folks or arab
folks do anything it's immediately a
form of terror
it's immediately classified as like some
national level threat but then when it's
a white person not only taking a life
yup now they're giving burger king not
only you know is there like an
idea of like well he just had a bad day
like you know let's cuddle this young
man and make it sound worse than what it
actually is
it almost sounds like they're
downplaying the implications and the
actions and the malice that is behind
people who take this action even when he
said he had a bad day it's not the
police chief that was saying that he had
a bad day it's not in the report that's
his words
no that was what he was claiming no no
no no no no no that's not doing whatever
i can put it back but it's not what he
said okay he was saying you know he's
someone who
had fed up and then he said and then he
had a bad day that was his words that
was his characterization that's not what
i heard
i heard according to him it's someone
that had a bad day the
bad day portion is his characterization
that's not what i understood
they got that impression that yes he he
understood um
the gravity of it and he was pretty much
fed up and
then kind of end of his rope and uh and
yesterday was a really bad day for him
and this is what he did
yeah when you characterize things in
such a positive light to make this
person just seem like
he had a long day i had a bad day attack
wow like when you make it sound like
that of course like it's not a grocery
store song i think
like what are you talking about right
they're willing to call us savages and
animals and like the most brutal thing
but when they talk about this stuff they
just make it sound much more palatable
the language surrounding perpetrators
when they happen to be white is so
empathetic and
it rubs you the wrong way because well
you do not accord that same level
of empathy and sympathy for black
defendants even when they're not guilty
or when you're uncertain you seem to be
so volatile but when they're victims of
perception i'm not saying it's rather
that's how people perceive it even me
i'll probably think about it that way so
i understand why people had such a
visceral reaction when they saw this
yeah of course
because people understand like
subtleties like he had a bad day he was
at the end of his rope
almost like he couldn't control himself
huh
what you drove around to a bunch of
spots you got your guns ready
ammunitions
you blasted all but you didn't
understand you premeditated the whole
thing
and when you were driving to another
spot to do more and
when you got caught you were on the way
to florida to do some more deeds
come on bro first thing i'm going to say
is this he's not putting his opinion
like
out there because he's not unable to he
cannot
it's in process right he can't say i
don't even understand
why they have these huddles with the
journalists and ask
he can't say anything and everything
else is going to be taken out of
proportion right
now right now the rhetoric is that oh he
never claimed that it was racially ma
the the police chief was not unable to
say that it was not no no
he was reporting what the suspect said
because he cannot
emit an opinion because that is gonna
change the whole thing
i don't even know why the police chief
always after all these grand things
happen
goes in front of the cameras and be like
um yeah next question
that's what he said i can't say okay
next question
yeah it's just in process i can't next
question
yep still i can't say they can't say so
there's nothing they can do about that
and then after that
it gets twisted and turned it he cannot
emit an opinion but people are like oh
he doesn't want to admit in the opinion
no he cannot okay i can because i'm not
a chief of police
the problem is not the language the
problem is the perceived double
standards which is very accurate yeah
the way that they cover trayvon martin
versus other people the way the pictures
that they use in the news like
we see it or people we see the
characterization of folks
or people that are even victims
affluence remember him
he was too rich to know what he was
doing was wrong what
they would never say that for a poor
person ever
even though poverty is a far more
adverse indicator of crime and
predictability but for rich person who
does something terrible they got
affluenza [ __ ] what
laughable he just caught the flu and
murdered people
what influenza no bro i'm
oh no bro yeah so that's what it is
if you guys feel some type of way about
this you're entitled to you guys are
very justified i get it
i i support it because you know what i
see the media [ __ ] happens i just
don't know why they still do these idols
and you want to hear the extra part
apparently this man got caught with
t-shirts that said cover 19
brought to you by china this man the
police chief had
t-shirts like that no yeah shut up
yeah yeah yeah it says brought to you by
china c-h-y-n-a
china really yeah so
perception-wise it looks terrible oh
wow you have what it appears to be let
me say this appears but not certainty
appears to be a racially motivated crime
by a white perpetrator
and then you also have a white police
chief kind of softening the blow
the optics look terrible oh yeah tail
looks bad so
yeah you know what my heart goes out of
victims and you know regards to what's
happening to asian folks like yo listen
it's a problem that's all i'm gonna say
i have no solutions i have nothing to
add what do you guys think do you guys
agree with some of the rhetoric do you
guys agree with the perception do you
think it's reality
we want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below i think there's a good
discussion to be had
why do we keep doing this and they can't
answer it's done